في ساحه الحريه وسط باخموت يتجول زعيم
الانفصاليين المولين لروسيا في منطقه
دوناتك قبل ان يلتقي في احد الانفاق
بعناصر من مجموعه فاجنر ويمنحهم ميداليه
الشجاعه السوفيتيه فيديو نشره عبر حسابه
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي من دون تحديد
تاريخ التقاط هذه الصور اليكم او بخموت
بالروسيه التي يتم تحريرها من قبل فاغنر
لم تستلم المدينه من العدو ولا سكانها
انهم يدفعون بهم الى الموت وفق دونيس
بوتشيلين نجحت قوات الكرملين ومقاتله
فاجنر في السيطره على اكثر من ثلثي باخمت
بعد التقدم باتجاه شمال وجنوب المدينه في
الاشهر الاخيره وقطع الكثير من طرق
الامداد الاوكرانيه والسيطره على الجزء
الشرقي منها لكن المعسكر الاخر يؤكد صمود
المدينه الشرقيه رغم الخسائر الكبيره التي
يتكبدها مع فقدان حوالي 100 طائره من دون
طيار في ساحه المعركه مع احتدام المعارك
بدا المع سكران يعتمدان على الطائرات
المسيره المزوده بالقنابل
[موسيقى]
كان ضبط القصف من مدافع الهاون يحتاج الى
مساح مثبت على تل اما اليوم وبفضل المسيره
يتمكن الجندي من تعديل توقيت القاء
القنبله بشكل فوري للصمود في وجه توغل
القوات الروسيه المدعومه من فاجنر يواصل
جنود الاوكرانيون تدريباتهم العسكريه على
بعد كيلومترات قليله من ضخمه لان استخدام
المسيرات وفق القوات الاوكرانيه ليس
بالامر السهل ويتطلب براعه وقدره على
المناوره لانجاز المهمه